right it's crunch time that exam is  coming up and it is not going to do  itself so down to you but that's good  because you have done so much work you  have tried so hard and put the amazeen  you've done past papers you have  literally the syllabus you are aware of  exactly what's expected of you and you  are squaring up to it and you are not  afraid you have absolutely got this  you're going to walk into that exam and  you're going to show everybody exactly  how much work you've been putting in  over the past weeks months even you got  to show everybody that you are a  champion because you want you were  already a champion you just need to show  everybody else that you've got this  you're going to be absolutely fine and  it's going to be amazing when you walk  out of that exam and you know you've  done well so go in there enjoy yourself  put everything you know down on that  exam paper and prove to people exactly  how great you are